le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
sur la côte ouest la sécheresse et le
vent rendent l'exploitation des champs
difficile pour établir un équilibre et
encourager l'agriculture dans cette
partie de l'île le département a réalisé
un chantier colossal de basculement des
eaux des stands ouest nicolas cultive la
canne à saint leu grâce à ce programme
d'irrigation du littoral ouest il a
presque doublé sa surface de production
[Musique]
il y a encore trois ans les buissons sec
et épineux s'étendait à perte de vue sur
ce terrain aujourd'hui nicolas carpi a
transformé le paysage sur cette parcelle
attribué par la safer en 2013 il cultive
désormais six hectares de cannes c'était
en friche on a fait de l'aménagement
foncier
passé le bull pour ailleurs et pour les
roches et non peuplée a fait des climats
sont
on a pu faire
si ce terrain a pu être réhabilité c'est
grâce à l'arrivée récente de l'eau
jusqu'aux champs en 2015 le département
inauguré la fin du grand chantier de
basculement des eaux des travaux
importants qui permettent de transférer
l'eau de la côte est très arrosée
jusqu'à la côte ouest extrêmement sèches
objectif permettre aux agriculteurs de
l'ouest de mieux exploiter leurs terres
et révéler le potentiel de ces parcelles
c'est via des stations de filtration que
l'eau est acheminée sur les terrains le
système d'irrigation est installé et
géré par la saphir les fondations
étaient préparés pour la course
mécanique donc aujourd'hui le système le
plus adapté c'est le seule goutte à
goutte après on a un phénomène de vent
sur le secteur qui n'est pas négligeable
donc c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a opté
pour le goutte-à-goutte parce qu'on a
des périodes de vent qui permettrait pas
d'optimiser son arrosage donc on y lit
serait obligée d'arrêter l'arrosage en
forant donc là avec le site en
goutte-à-goutte il peut irriguer ont
réalisé 24 heures sur 24 pratiquement
autres avantages l'eau peut être mélangé
directement aux fertilisants
l'agriculteur peut alors se concentrer
sur ses récoltes la seule manipulation
qu'il a à faire c'est de mettre de
l'anglais dans le temps donc là il
arrive avec les sags d'enlever il met
dedans après effectivement tout le
fonctionnement de
la parcelle est automatique
pour les quarts pis c'est une grande
révolution dans cette famille on est
agriculteur de génération en génération
les parents de nicola cultiver aussi la
can mais à l'époque sans eau les
conditions étaient plus difficiles pas
on attend dès lors qu'apparaît caprices
de la nature on attendait que la pluie
arrive et puis on emmenait beaucoup de
fumée de l'assemblée ainsi tué et puis
complet mais il fallait vraiment
vraiment attendre que la pluie au cas
contraire les rendements bas c'était pas
ça non plus on faisait du 81
70 80 90 tonnes et a aujourd'hui
germaniques ont à lui et peut faire du
180 200 e année de la fête 221 états
étaient par contre
au louvre en crise est aussi de
travailler sans l'os et 80 en face ont
discrètement est un vecteur pouvoir moi
même ni voix aux dépens des hommes donc
avec l'arrivée de l'os et
cette année la famille carpi espère
faire encore mieux les cannes sont
belles et grandes et promettent un bon
rendement
la peur
malgré un investissement important et
beaucoup de sacrifices il n'est pas
toujours facile de vivre de ses récoltes
l'irrigation du littoral ouest offre de
nouvelles perspectives aux agriculteurs
nous avons encore de forts potentiels en
matière de terres incultes ou de terres
en friche et c'est vrai que nous aidons
à apporter de l'eau aux agriculteurs
mais en globalité et dans la vision ce
quand vous habitez sur une île l'eau est
une denrée précieuse
il ya donc à définir une gestion globale
de l'eau sur l'ensemble de la réunion où
on puisse avoir le même prix de l'eau le
même tarif quelle que soit la ville où
vous habitez et donc les élus que nous
sommes nous devons pour les 20 ans qui
viennent définir un schéma stratégique
un schéma sur la gestion durable et
globale de l'eau respectueuse de
l'environnement sans qu'il y ait de
gaspillage et en faisant en sorte que
cette denrée puisse être assurée sur
toutes les années à venir sur l'avenir
pour nos petits enfants et nos enfants
[Musique]
le projet d'irrigation du littoral ouest
consiste à transférer de l'eau depuis sa
l'asie en passant par mafate jusqu'à la
côte ouest de l'île pour ce faire une
galerie souterraine de 30 km et quatre
ouvrages de captage ont été réalisés
ce projet a trois objectifs irrigué plus
de 7000 hectares de terres agricoles
apporter un complément de ressources en
eau aux communes de l'ouest et recharger
la nappe de la rivière des galets
pour plus d'informations sur le projet
d'irrigation du littoral ouest rendez
vous sur le site du département ou
www.cc de 7,4 point fr
[Musique]
m